イージー種
ん
younger
僕のすごく好きな言葉です
この言葉を聞くと僕は一人じゃない
パワーをいただく言葉
それがこのやんかです
これを僕は聞くためにいろいろなことを仕掛ける
その一つの成果がですねこれです
鹿児島5253祭
僕ら同級生だけが参加できる非日常な空間
それが
5253祭りです
みてください
はじめましての方もいるし久しぶりという方
この時に168名の同級生が集まりました
この笑顔であったり
は久しぶりだねとかこの回開いてくれてありがとう
そう言うことを聞くと先ほどのやんかをやってよかったな
僕はすごくそう思ってます
今からお話しするやんか
これの
新しい世界に導くキーワードだと思っています
でもこれは僕だけの特別なことではない
あなたもできる
やんかを導き出すことができる秘密その5つの秘訣を今から皆さんにお伝えしたいと
思います
一つ目
べ愛を繰り返せ
二つ目口は塞いだ口の下である
みつめキースを集めを
4つ目未来を今決める
5つ目
これはですねちょっと後からお伝えしたいと思いますこの5つ
今からお伝えします
一つで愛を繰り返せ
多分皆さん何のこっちゃ
よくわからない思ってらっしゃる方いらっしゃるかもしれない
今からすごくわかりやすく説明します
書いてあります出会い
書いてあります
出会う繰り返しますよ見ててくださいね
抱卵繰り返した
たった1個の出会いが休校になりました
ねまだ繰り返します出会いを繰り返します
画面いっぱいの出会いになりました
ここにある物が隠されているんですよ
気づきますか
どうでしょう
アユやです
出会いを繰り返すとアイディアが隠れてるんですね
先ほどから言ってる逆がー
5253が付いの薬がこれもあるひとつの出会いから生まれたアイディアなんです
その1層が一つお話しするのですが私は地元が大好きです
その大好きな地元にたまたまできた
すごい美味しいとんかつ屋ができたんですねそのとんかつ屋
彼のところでご飯を食べる
カウンター越しで店主と会話をする
そうすると共通項が見つかったんです
あら同級生だねっ
そう5253の仲間だったんです
僕は愛すべき地元に
美味しいとんかつ屋できてそれをいろんなところに広めたいなと考えたんです
そして色々妄想した結果
彼とは学校が違ったんですね
学校が違った普通同窓会というと学校単位でありますよね
学校の単位の壁をブチ壊して同級生だけ集まれる
お祭りをしようじゃないかということで始まった
妄想なんですそれが先ほど言った5253祭
ある一つの出会いから生まれたアイディア
それが
この出会いを繰り返したことによって導かれた
やっぱです
二つ目
の不潔
これは履くという感じです皆さん
会場にながら息を吸ったり吐いたりしていると思う
僕はここで言葉を発しています
入っています
吐くという感じすごい面白いんですねちょっと分解してみますね
こうあります
口
プラスマイナスこの3つから吐くという言葉は
成り立っています
そのうちですね口から発すること
マイナスのこと
プラスのこともマイナスのことっていうのはですね僕は3 d 言葉と言ってるんです
けどでもとかだってとかどうせ
会話でこういう会話が出てくると先ほど言ったやがっていうのには繋がらないことが
多いです
マイナス言葉はやがの火を消してしまうんですね
逆にプラスの言葉を使うと親がが加速されるんですよ
その
答えをお伝えすると口から
マイナス音博から毎夏を取ればこの感じになるんですね
わかりますね叶う
力出す言葉をプラスにすることだけで叶うんです
そういう時ぜひ使ってほしい言葉が素直である
素直な言葉を使ってほしい
具体的に言えばすごいですねとかなるほどですねとか面白いですね
頭の家で綱をです
そういう素直な心で花やを交わすことが出来れば先ほどの家が
が
より実現性を帯びてくる
2つ目はお
さあの先ほど行った口は塞いだ口のもとプラスもマイナスも発することが出来ますが
+を出しましょう
3つ目金子であるということですピースを集めようということですね
ピース2つ意味があります一つ目はやっぱり人なんですね
先ほどの5253祭これは40歳で1000人で乾杯するという
アホなアイディアです
でも今僕らそのアホな夢に向かって
着実に一つずつ階段を上っています
つまり1000個のピースを集めないといけないですね1000人集めるということは
そのためにやはり
仲間を集めないといけないんですよ
で仲間はですねどう集めるか出来るところと出来ないところそれぞれあるんです
僕はデザイナーでもありませんしあの何か
緻密なキャッチコピーを考えることができるようなキャラではないです
ただこうしてみんなに会いでぇを伝えたりすることは得意です僕はそういう訳で御
253に貢献しているし
同じ仲間は違うことで貢献している
そういう仲間がですねピースがそろって
初めて大きな絵が描ける
もう一つは
ピースあつめのもう一つの日は経験値なんですね
ネタいろんなことを経験するそうすると一つずつ
ピースを手に入れることができる大きな絵を描きたい
その時に今すぐははまらないかもしれないけどどこかではハマるかもしれない
ピースが手に入るんです
一つエピソードとして言えば5253祭は
屋台村を貸切りました民間では初です
いきなり僕らが貸し切れたっていう実績はですね僕が日頃から屋台村で飲みに行って
たっていうただそれだけなんです
屋台村を貸切るためにのみてたんですたまたまのに入ってた
そこで屋台村関係者さんとすごく仲良くなった
普通にお話ができる中になった
そうして実はこういう企画があるのです
そうすると人となりわかってますでどういう良い影響を与えるか
彼はよくわかってた
双子と編でしたいいよ
すごいあっけにとられましたもちろんその後はちゃんとした
稟議書を出しましたけれども
そう
このピースを集めるということがすごく重要です
4つ目の秘訣です
これ僕は普段愛用している
スケジュール超絶でかいです
この中身こんな感じではいろいろぐっちゃぐちゃ書いてます
未来を今決めるということはですね皆さんこういう経験ないですか
またの三江姐とかまた今度それしようねっ
その約束って
実現できました
結構できてないことをオイッ
かもしれません
であればですね私は伝えたい
今その瞬間一番ホットな時に4点を決めてください
未来は今決めれるんです
僕らは40歳で乾杯するということを決めたそれを逆算してただいまやっているだけ
です
未来は今作っている
5つ目
出てきました
これ僕の筆文字だめですが
これ
読み方わかる方いますか
まあ普通はですね近く同公邸をの方がほとんどです
僕も初めて見た時はそう感じましたでもこの読み方はぜひ覚えていただきたい
知覚動考
ありますともがく動くをよくとにかく動こうぜってあると思うんですが
少しちょっと変えて知覚動考
知って覚えて動きながら考えろ
家がを作り出したい加速させたい引き出したい
そういう方
いろんなことを知って覚えて人に伝える
とりあえずやる
とにかく動く
この知覚動考このキーワードはすごく
重要だと僕は思う
僕がただ口だけで言っている男であれば
みんなの屋号多分は引き出せなかった
日頃から小さなことでも構わないそういうことを
線して動いて実践して皆さんに伝えていく
こういうことを繰り返すことで
先ほどの5253祭40歳で仙人乾杯は
今実現に向かってひた走っています
5つのキーワード
秘訣
覚えてますか出会いを繰り返せ
口は塞いだ口の下であるだから+のことを言いましょう
キースを集めてくださいみなさんの周りに絶対いるはずです
皆さんの
苦手なところできていないところを補ってくれる仲間が後
経験値ででアイデ
薬がを引き出すことができる
それは
夢ではなく
計画予定確定した未来にしてください
それで
で覚えて動きながら考える
これはすべて
先ほどから僕がいう訳か
鹿児島弁で
やるが
やブラッド薬なんかそれいいねそういうことにつながるキーワードです
kagoshima university の今回のテックス kagoshima
university のキーワード
テーマ
first story です
皆さんの
first story ぜひや花で作ってみませんか
ありがとうござました